bienvenue dans Quantum Computing en pratique, je suis Olivia Lan et l'épisode trois d'aujourd'hui va se concentrer sur une
expérience qaoa à l'échelle utilitaire si tu nous suis depuis le début tu nous as vus parcourir
le matériel IBM Quantum, le framework des patterns Qiskit et les dernières techniques de mitigation d'erreurs les plus avancées que
les chercheurs et développeurs utilisent pour faire passer les quantum circuits à l'échelle nous avons pensé qu'il était vraiment important de te donner tout ce
contexte et de te montrer la direction que nous prenions mais maintenant il n'y a plus aucune raison d'attendre plus longtemps pour voir toutes ces informations en
action voici quelques points à garder en tête avant de commencer tout va suivre le framework des patterns
Qiskit donc nous allons parcourir ces étapes dans l'ordre : numéro un c'est la mise en correspondance du problème, deux l'optimisation du circuit, trois
l'exécution avec les Primitives et quatre le post-traitement ou l'analyse des résultats on va commencer par un exemple assez petit
pour que vous puissiez tous bien saisir ces étapes et leur utilité ensuite on discutera d'un exemple très similaire mais beaucoup
plus grand pour te montrer comment on ferait passer le problème au niveau des 100 qubit je vais te donner tous les
outils pour te permettre d'aller de l'avant après cette leçon et de faire tourner ce problème de manière autonome enfin ceci ne va pas
être un tutoriel de code peu importe nos efforts au fur et à mesure que nous avançons le code vieillit et devient obsolète donc si tu regardes
cette vidéo un an après son lancement je ne veux pas que tu te bloques sur la syntaxe qui pourrait légèrement changer avec le temps à la place ce sera une
discussion détaillée de la logique et de l'énoncé du problème cependant il y a un tutoriel sous forme de notebook qui accompagne cette
vidéo et qui est joint dans la description ci-dessous suivre le code ou y faire référence après avoir
regardé cette leçon et le faire tourner toi-même te donnera la meilleure expérience d'apprentissage possible donc pour rappel
tous les problèmes informatiques ne sont pas adaptés au Quantum Computing les problèmes faciles et les calculs simples n'ont pas besoin de tirer
parti de cette technologie car les ordinateurs classiques s'en sortent déjà très bien pour les résoudre à partir de 2024
les trois domaines sur lesquels nous sommes les plus optimistes sont : la simulation de la nature, le traitement de données à structure complexe
et enfin l'optimisation les problèmes d'optimisation sont parmi les problèmes informatiques les plus difficiles
à résoudre efficacement dans un problème d'optimisation tu cherches la valeur la plus grande ou la plus petite possible
pour une fonction de coût donnée cependant pour beaucoup de problèmes d'intérêt trouver cet extremum devient exponentiellement plus
difficile avec la taille du problème c'est pourquoi ça devient si difficile à calculer par exemple tu peux imaginer à quel point
il peut être difficile de calculer les routes de vol optimales ou les itinéraires de livraison à travers le pays dans cette leçon nous allons
explorer un problème d'optimisation particulier appelé Max cut que nous allons résoudre en utilisant un
algorithme quantique appelé quantum approximation optimization algorithm ou qaoa alors c'est quoi le problème Max cut
un problème de coupe maximale est un type de problème d'optimisation combinatoire défini sur un graphe où l'objectif est de
partitionner les sommets du graphe en deux sous-ensembles de manière à ce que le nombre d'arêtes entre les deux sous-ensembles soit
maximisé donc par exemple dans ce graphe ici chaque nœud est connecté comme ça et la coupe max est représentée par cette ligne ondulée
qui divise les nœuds en groupe violet et groupe gris la façon de faire ça en traversant le plus grand
nombre d'arêtes possible est de couper à travers cinq arêtes pour ce graphe ici parce que le graphe est si petit
il n'est pas difficile d'essayer quelques coupes possibles sur papier ou même dans ta tête et de comprendre que cinq est la meilleure option possible
mais imagine si le nombre de nœuds doublait puis triplait ça devient rapidement impossible à faire
à la main et après un certain nombre ça devient si difficile que même les supercalculateurs ont du mal à retourner la meilleure réponse de manière fiable c'est parce que
le nombre maximum de coupes évolue de manière exponentielle avec le nombre de nœuds même si ça peut sembler un peu abstrait
il y a beaucoup de problèmes du monde réel qui peuvent être formulés comme un problème Max cut comme la détection de fraude en finance le partitionnement de graphes
la conception de réseaux et la conception VLSI ainsi que l'analyse des réseaux sociaux
celui des réseaux sociaux est particulièrement facile à saisir disons que tu veux trouver un groupe d'individus qui ont le plus de connexions possibles
avec d'autres individus sur une plateforme de réseau social afin d'identifier les utilisateurs influents ou les personnes qui ont
le plus d'influence dans un groupe les entreprises essaient réellement de faire ça assez fréquemment un dernier point ici la coupe max est souvent
une sous-routine d'un problème plus grand donc elle ne définit peut-être pas l'application réelle mais utilisée en arrière-plan c'est
beaucoup plus courant que tu ne le penserais naïvement maintenant il est temps de commencer
la première étape est de créer notre graphe tu peux faire ça en important un package python appelé rust Works définis combien
de nœuds tu utilises en spécifiant le nombre n puis ajoute tes nœuds au graphe G tu devras aussi
dessiner tes arêtes on va le faire manuellement ici en les listant simplement dans un tableau comme ça où tu montres le dernier
nombre qui spécifie le poids de l'arête ou la force de la connexion entre les deux nœuds spécifiés ici on va juste
s'en tenir à un poids de un pour tous mais tu pourrais aimer jouer avec le poids plus tard et voir comment la solution
change pour mieux comprendre ce que signifie le poids dans ce contexte retournons à notre exemple de réseau social tu peux
penser à ce poids comme à l'influence qu'une personne pourrait avoir sur une autre ta connexion avec ton conjoint ou un proche
par exemple se verrait probablement attribuer un poids plus élevé que quelqu'un qui n'est qu'une connaissance maintenant dessine ton graphe
le tutoriel joint te montrera la syntaxe correcte d'abord avant de réfléchir à comment
mettre en correspondance ce problème sur un quantum circuit construisons un peu de contexte sur comment le problème Max cut devient un problème d'optimisation
au départ on commence par considérer la minimisation d'une fonction f de x où l'entrée X est un
vecteur de dimension n dont les composantes correspondent à chaque nœud du graphe on fera référence à cette fonction désormais
comme notre fonction de coût puis on doit contraindre chacune de ces composantes à être soit zéro soit
un ici ce qui signifie d'un côté ou de l'autre de la coupe on peut écrire une fonction comme
une paire de nœuds x i et xj qui nous indique si l'arête correspondante est dans la coupe ainsi plus la quantité x i + xj
moins x i xj indique si l'arête est dans la coupe si cette quantité est égale
à un cela implique que l'arête est dans la coupe sinon elle est à zéro et l'arête ne l'est pas le problème de trouver le
nombre maximum d'arêtes dans la coupe peut alors être formulé comme la maximisation de cette fonction ensuite on va
ajouter un signe moins global à cette fonction rendant le nouveau problème équivalent à trouver le minimum de cette fonction
WEBVTT
au lieu de ça et donc le minimum de f de x dans ce cas sera quand le nombre d'arêtes traversées par la coupe est
maximal on choisit de formuler ce problème comme un problème de minimisation parce que cela nous permet de le mapper ensuite sur un
problème de minimisation d'énergie c'est-à-dire trouver l'état fondamental ce pour quoi les ordinateurs quantiques sont naturellement très bons
mais rappelle-toi qu'il n'y a encore rien lié au Quantum Computing ici on doit encore reformuler ce problème en
quelque chose qu'un ordinateur quantique peut comprendre on est maintenant prêts à s'y mettre sérieusement et à commencer le travail
la première étape est de mapper le problème sur un quantum circuit ça ne semble peut-être pas évident comment on va
passer d'un graphe comme celui qu'on vient de dessiner à un quantum circuit mais prenons ça lentement rappelle-toi que l'on va
essayer de résoudre ce problème Max cut en utilisant qaoa dans l'algorithme qaoa on veut finalement avoir un opérateur
le hamiltonien qui sera utilisé pour représenter la fonction de coût de notre problème ainsi qu'un
circuit paramétré le ansatz ou l'état d'essai qu'on utilisera pour représenter des états quantiques qui sont des suppositions éclairées ou des candidats
à la solution du problème on peut échantillonner ces états candidats et les évaluer
en utilisant la fonction de coût dans ce cas la fonction de coût est f de x mais on doit l'exprimer d'une
manière qui semble naturelle à l'ordinateur quantique pour ça on va tirer parti d'une série de transformations
mathématiques pour exprimer f de x comme une fonction d'énergie le hamiltonien la première étape du
processus est d'exprimer le problème de minimisation de f de x comme un problème d'optimisation binaire quadratique non contraint
ou QUBO en abrégé QUBO est une manière générale de formuler ces problèmes d'optimisation combinatoire
ici Q est une matrice N par N de nombres réels N correspond au nombre de
nœuds dans notre graphe cinq pour cet exemple et X est le même vecteur de variables binaires de la
formulation initiale pour exécuter efficacement l'algorithme qaoa on doit exprimer notre problème d'optimisation en termes de
hamiltonien qui est un opérateur mathématique représentant l'énergie totale d'un système plus précisément on veut
créer un hamiltonien de fonction de coût qui a la propriété que son énergie d'état fondamental ou valeur propre minimale
correspond au minimum de la fonction qui encode le nombre maximum de coupes sur le graphe g une fois qu'on
a ce hamiltonien tout ce qu'on doit faire pour résoudre notre problème d'optimisation c'est de préparer l'état fondamental du hamiltonien sur l'ordinateur quantique puis
l'échantillonnage de cet état donnera avec une haute probabilité la solution à la minimisation de f de x il s'avère
qu'on a de la chance parce que le problème QUBO est très étroitement lié et en réalité computationnellement équivalent à
l'un des hamiltoniens les plus célèbres et omniprésents en physique le hamiltonien d'Ising pour écrire le problème QUBO
comme ce hamiltonien d'Ising tout ce qu'on doit faire en réalité c'est un simple changement de variable pour passer de
variables booléennes 0 et 1 à des variables de spin moins un et un cette étape est
simple elle est présentée plus en détail dans l'annexe du notebook joint pour ceux que ça intéresse mais au final la minimisation de cette expression QUBO
est la même que la minimisation de cette expression en réécrivant légèrement à nouveau
on obtient notre hamiltonien de fonction de coût où le minimum de l'expression représente l'état fondamental et Z
devient l'opérateur de Pauli tandis que B est un coefficient scalaire réel maintenant qu'on a notre
hamiltonien il est simple de le réécrire en termes de deux opérateurs de Pauli ZZ locaux qui se convertiront facilement en
deux gates ZZ dans notre quantum circuit réfère-toi au notebook associé pour voir comment c'est fait mais le résultat
est donné par cette ligne ici note que dans notre exemple il y a
six objets ou chaînes de Pauli parce que chacun représente une arête dans le graphe la longueur de la chaîne correspond au nombre
de nœuds donc I I I ZZ représente cinq nœuds et la chaîne sera composée de
l'identité à toutes les positions sauf pour les indices des nœuds impliqués dans une arête qui auront des termes Z dans Qiskit
les chaînes de bits représentant les qubit sont indexées à l'envers par exemple une arête entre les nœuds 0 et 1 sera encodée comme
I I I ZZ avec le hamiltonien écrit en termes de Pauli on est prêts à construire notre
quantum circuit ce quantum circuit va nous aider à échantillonner de bonnes solutions depuis l'ordinateur quantique l'algorithme qaoa
est inspiré du théorème adiabatique qui stipule que si on commence dans l'état fondamental du
hamiltonien dépendant du temps et si le hamiltonien évolue assez lentement et avec suffisamment de temps l'état final sera l'état fondamental
du hamiltonien final qaoa peut être perçu comme la version de Trotter discrète de l'algorithme
adiabatique quantique où chaque pas de Trotter représente une couche qu'on appellera P donc
au lieu d'évoluer d'un état à l'autre dans chaque couche de P on va alterner entre notre
hamiltonien de fonction de coût et quelque chose qu'on appelle notre hamiltonien mixer dont on va entendre parler dans un instant mais le point que je veux souligner
c'est que qaoa a l'avantage d'être plus rapide que l'algorithme adiabatique quantique mais il retourne des solutions
approximatives plutôt qu'optimales dans la limite où le nombre de couches tend vers l'infini qaoa converge vers le cas
adiabatique mais bien sûr c'est très coûteux en termes de calcul pour créer notre quantum circuit
on va appliquer des opérateurs alternatifs ici paramétrés par gamma et beta qui
représenteront la discrétisation de l'évolution temporelle donc encore les trois parties principales
du circuit qaoa sont : un l'état d'essai initial en gris qui est l'état fondamental
du mixer à partir de l'état adiabatique d'évolution créé en appliquant un gate Hadamard appliqué à chaque qubit deux
l'évolution de la fonction de coût qu'on a déjà en violet foncé et trois l'évolution sous le hamiltonien
mixer qu'on n'a pas encore discuté en violet clair maintenant notre hamiltonien de départ est
appelé le mixer parce que son état fondamental est la superposition de toutes les chaînes de bits possibles d'intérêt ce qui
impose un mélange de toutes les solutions possibles au départ le hamiltonien mixer est la simple somme des opérations de Pauli X
sur chaque nœud du graphe Qiskit te permet d'utiliser un opérateur mixer personnalisé différent si tu le souhaites mais
pour ce cas on va juste utiliser celui standard donc encore tu peux voir qu'avec Qiskit une grande partie du travail est
faite pour nous rendant la création du hamiltonien mixer et de l'état de départ triviale le seul travail qu'on a dû faire était
WEBVTT
de trouver la fonction de coût chaque itération de ces opérateurs est appelée une couche ces couches peuvent être vues comme des
discrétisations de l'évolution temporelle du système comme décrit précédemment le motif alternatif vient de la
décomposition de Trotter et approxime les fonctions exponentielles de matrices non commutatives en général plus on inclut de couches ou de
pas plus on sera proche de l'évolution continue dans le temps donc en théorie plus le résultat sera précis
mais pour cet exemple on va commencer par échantillonner avec deux couches rappelle-toi que le hamiltonien de fonction de coût et
le mixer sont tous les deux paramétrés on doit encore trouver des valeurs optimales pour gamma et
beta maintenant je reconnais que c'était beaucoup d'informations et si tu vois ce type de math pour la première fois ça peut être difficile heureusement l'une des choses fantastiques
avec Qiskit c'est qu'une grande partie de ce qu'on vient de voir peut être fait automatiquement sans énorme effort de la part de l'utilisateur c'est bien de comprendre ce qui se passe
sous le capot surtout quand on passe à des expériences plus grandes mais tu n'auras pas à faire tout ce travail
manuellement à chaque fois on a maintenant mappé notre problème sur un quantum circuit c'était un peu de travail
mais ne t'inquiète pas ça devient plus facile et plus intuitif plus tu le fais on est maintenant prêts à passer à l'étape deux
l'optimisation de notre circuit pour le matériel donc bien que le circuit qu'on vient de créer semble assez simple et soit
utile pour développer une compréhension intuitive rappelle-toi que la puce quantique ne comprend pas ce que ce bloc
abstrait est on doit le transformer en une série de gates à un et deux qubit qui sont natifs au matériel et quand je dis
natif je veux dire qu'il sera refactorisé en ce qui peut être exécuté directement sur les qubit ces circuits sont
dits écrits dans l'architecture de jeu d'instructions du backend ce qu'on pourrait voir abrégé en circuits ISA
le module transpiler du SDK Qiskit offre une série de passes de transpilation qui peuvent
effectuer une large gamme de transformations de circuit on veut s'assurer que notre circuit est optimisé pour notre
usage rappelle-toi de notre leçon précédente que le processus de transpilation comprend plusieurs étapes : la mise en correspondance des
qubit dans le circuit ou les variables de décision aux qubit physiques sur le dispositif le déroulement des instructions dans
le quantum circuit vers les instructions natives au matériel que le backend comprend réellement le routage des
qubit dans le circuit qui interagissent directement vers des qubit physiques qui sont adjacents les uns
aux autres et comme toujours plus de détails à ce sujet peuvent être trouvés sur le site de
documentation vient maintenant une étape passionnante où on va choisir quel backend utiliser pour faire tourner notre circuit on doit en fait faire ça
avant l'étape de transpilation parce que le transpiler optimise différemment pour différents processeurs c'est encore une autre raison pour laquelle il est
important que Qiskit puisse automatiser une si grande partie de cette étape tu ne voudrais pas avoir à optimiser ton circuit manuellement
ce qui peut être fait mais c'est parfois difficile et très chronophage pour te rendre compte finalement que tu veux faire tourner
ton circuit sur un processeur différent avec des propriétés différentes et alors tu dois refaire tout ce travail depuis le début passe
ton backend de choix dans la fonction transpiler et n'oublie pas de spécifier ton niveau d'optimisation cette
fois j'ai sélectionné le niveau d'optimisation trois qui est le plus élevé et le plus exhaustif niveau d'optimisation
et c'est en fait tout pour l'étape deux mon circuit a été transpilé automatiquement et je l'ai dessiné ici pour que
tu puisses voir comment il a été traduit en gates à un et deux qubit il est maintenant temps pour l'étape trois
faire tourner le circuit avec les Primitives Qiskit jusqu'ici on a transpilé le circuit en laissant les paramètres gamma et
beta de côté mais on ne peut pas vraiment faire tourner le circuit sans spécifier la valeur de ces paramètres dans le
workflow qaoa les paramètres qaoa optimaux sont trouvés dans une boucle d'optimisation itérative où on fait tourner une série d'évaluations de circuit
et on utilise un optimiseur classique pour trouver les paramètres beta et gamma optimaux cependant on doit commencer
quelque part donc j'ai implémenté quelques suppositions initiales pour Gamma 1 gamma 2 et beta 1 beta 2 de Pi / 2 et Pi
respectivement je veux aussi que tu notes qu'on va utiliser un optimiseur pour trouver de meilleures solutions pour gamma et beta
et puisque je calcule seulement deux couches pour l'instant c'est tout ce dont j'ai besoin mais si tu crées un circuit qaoa plus précis
tu inclurais plus de couches et aurais donc besoin d'un gamma et beta optimisés pour chaque couche
séquentielle maintenant prenons juste une minute ici pour faire une pause et nous souvenir de nos options pour les Primitives on a l'estimator et
le sampler lequel tu penses qu'on va utiliser pour ce type de travail eh bien peu importe celui que tu as
deviné tu as en fait raison on va utiliser à la fois l'estimator et le sampler pour l'
boucle d'optimisation initiale on aura besoin de l'estimator mais on utilisera le sampler plus tard pour lire la solution finale
maintenant on est presque prêts à faire tourner notre algorithme je te le promets mais très rapidement il est important de noter que tu peux
soumettre ton travail de différentes façons qu'on appelle des modes d'exécution d'abord on a le mode job une seule
requête primitive de l'estimator ou du sampler faite sans gestionnaire de contexte les circuits et les entrées sont emballés en blocs unifiés
de primitive appelés pubs et soumis comme une tâche d'exécution sur l'ordinateur
quantique le mode batch est un gestionnaire multi-tâches pour exécuter efficacement une expérience composée d'un ensemble
de tâches indépendantes utilise le mode batch pour soumettre plusieurs tâches de primitives simultanément le mode session est une fenêtre dédiée
pour exécuter une charge de travail multi-tâches cela permet aux utilisateurs premium d'expérimenter avec des algorithmes variationnels de manière plus
prévisible et même d'exécuter plusieurs expériences simultanément en tirant parti du parallélisme de la
pile utilise les sessions pour les workflows itératifs et les expériences qui nécessitent un accès dédié pour une expérience qaoa
une session serait un bon choix à adopter si tu y as accès puisque tu devras essayer plusieurs circuits pour différentes valeurs de beta
et gamma bon maintenant revenons à notre problème d'optimisation on a déjà
défini le hamiltonien de fonction de coût HC et le workflow complet est le suivant l'algorithme qaoa
commence par initialiser les qubit dans l'état de superposition puis applique le ansatz avec P couches il
initialise les paramètres gamma et beta puis fait tourner le circuit en utilisant la primitive estimator une fois qu'on calcule
les valeurs d'espérance on utilisera ensuite un optimiseur SciPy appelé COBYLA COBYLA
optimise la fonction de coût classiquement en dehors du QPU une fois que ces valeurs de gamma et beta ont été mises à jour on
recommence on va faire ça jusqu'à ce que la valeur de la fonction de coût globale ait convergé et atteint la valeur la plus basse
WEBVTT
ensuite on va sélectionner les valeurs de gamma et beta qui correspondent à cette valeur de coût faible et faire tourner le circuit une dernière
fois maintenant en utilisant le sampler voici le résultat de l'exécution de l'optimiseur COBYLA avec mes suppositions initiales ici tu peux voir
que la valeur de la fonction de coût au fil des itérations effectuées commence un peu erratiquement elle monte et descend mais
ensuite elle se stabilise à une valeur basse on va utiliser ces dernières valeurs de gamma et beta qui correspondent au coût
minimum pour faire tourner le circuit une dernière fois et échantillonner la chaîne de bits qui nous donnera la coupe
maximale maintenant en utilisant nos valeurs optimisées pour les gammas et betas on va faire tourner le circuit une dernière fois pour trouver la meilleure
chaîne de bits possible en utilisant le sampler j'ai listé les valeurs spécifiques que j'utilise ici mais rappelle-toi que quand tu essaies
ta chance ou même que tu relances simplement le même notebook de tutoriel ces valeurs pourraient changer légèrement maintenant on va faire tourner
notre circuit optimisé avec ces valeurs et trouver notre solution candidate à notre problème Max cut si tu utilisais
des sessions ce n'est plus nécessaire puisqu'on fait juste tourner un dernier travail maintenant on va enfin regarder l'étape de
post-traitement et la recherche de notre solution finale d'abord traçons toutes les
combinaisons possibles de nœuds qu'on a converties en chaînes de bits sous forme d'histogramme tu peux voir tout de suite que
quand je l'ai fait tourner j'ai trouvé quatre solutions et mis en évidence en violet celles qui sont plus probables que toute autre solution
la chaîne de bits la plus haute et donc la plus probable est 0 1 01 note bien l'ordre des qubit
est inversé dans le graphique en regardant la solution la plus probable on note que les nœuds 0 et trois sont groupés ensemble
et de même pour les nœuds 1 2 et quatre on peut enfin tracer la chaîne de bits la plus probable
sous forme de graphe et rappelle-toi que la chaîne de bits correspond simplement aux numéros de nœuds et s'ils sont inclus
marqués d'un un ou non inclus marqués d'un zéro dans notre regroupement quand on dessine la coupe maintenant on peut voir à l'œil nu
la ligne approximative pour la meilleure coupe qui représente simplement le regroupement idéal des cinq nœuds que j'ai dessinée ici
il y a une chose sur laquelle je veux passer un peu de temps ici cependant c'est le fait que la solution correcte n'est pas unique
en raison de la symétrie de ce graphe il y a plusieurs solutions correctes au lieu d'avoir les nœuds 0 et trois à l'intérieur
de la coupe on pourrait avoir les nœuds 2 et quatre inclus et tu peux voir que tout ce que j'ai eu à faire c'est de faire pivoter ma coupe pour
inclure ces nouveaux points cette solution de cinq reste la même
regardons encore une fois l'histogramme et les quatre solutions les plus probables pendant une minute les deux dernières solutions sont les
deux qu'on vient de tracer et elles sont tout aussi correctes mais ce n'est pas tout on pourrait aussi inverser les couleurs pour toutes
les solutions correctes et cette fois on pense juste aux nœuds comme étant à l'intérieur versus à l'extérieur de la coupe sur la
diapositive précédente on a identifié deux solutions correctes uniques mais il y a en réalité deux autres solutions l'une correspondant à
l'opposé de chacune d'elles vois comment ici où j'ai dessiné les deux solutions restantes tout ce que j'ai fait c'est d'inverser les
couleurs maintenant le seul problème c'est que l'algorithme n'a pas réellement trouvé ou identifié cette quatrième et dernière solution comme
étant l'une des quatre réponses les plus probables c'était la cinquième la quatrième solution que l'algorithme a identifiée
est en réalité incorrecte et si tu la dessinais tu verrais que cette solution n'a que quatre coupes et puisque les autres
en ont cinq et que quatre est clairement inférieur à cinq c'est évidemment faux le point ici
c'est que c'est un algorithme approximatif il n'est pas infaillible et il n'est pas correct à 100% du temps tu dois
utiliser tes propres connaissances et ta compréhension pour vérifier la cohérence des solutions il vaut la peine de souligner que
cette erreur peut provenir de plusieurs endroits cela pourrait être la nature approximative de l'algorithme lui-même et le petit
nombre de couches que j'ai choisi d'utiliser cela pourrait être une erreur d'échantillonnage fini et cela pourrait être réduit si j'augmente le
nombre de shots dans mon expérience ou cela pourrait être une erreur de lecture puisque la quatrième vraie solution n'est décalée que d'un
bit la raison pour laquelle je signale toutes ces possibilités c'est parce que c'est ce qu'il faut pour devenir véritablement un
praticien du Quantum Computing tu dois comprendre les performances du matériel et comment cela peut contribuer
à certains types d'erreurs et comment les corriger cependant n'oublions pas qu'il y avait
32 solutions de chaînes de bits possibles et que les quatre vraies solutions étaient incluses dans les cinq meilleures
candidates et je n'ai utilisé que deux couches pour trouver ça en général si je veux augmenter mes chances de trouver la
meilleure coupe Max à chaque fois j'augmenterais la profondeur des couches il y a quelques subtilités à ça mais c'est pour un prochain
épisode maintenant je vais te laisser essayer ta chance toi-même mais cette fois tu vas utiliser 100
qubit donc si on commence par dessiner notre graphe à 100 qubit tu peux voir qu'il n'est plus simple ni même possible
d'estimer à vue d'œil où la coupe max se produirait il y a tout simplement trop de possibilités pour pouvoir la repérer manuellement mais
résoudre ce problème en utilisant qaoa est encore totalement faisable et tu peux suivre exactement le même workflow qu'on a utilisé pour 5
qubit je suis sur le point de t'envoyer de ton côté et de te charger d'essayer de faire cette expérience mais avant que je le fasse
faisons un résumé rappelle-toi que les six étapes de n'importe quel travail qaoa sont les suivantes : un définir
un hamiltonien de coût tel que son état fondamental encode la solution au problème d'optimisation deux définir un
hamiltonien mixer trois construire les opérateurs correspondant aux hamiltoniens
exponentiés quatre construire le circuit il sera composé de l'état fondamental initial du mixer et de couches alternées
répétées de la fonction de coût et de l'évolution sous les hamiltoniens mixer cinq préparer un état initial et
utiliser des techniques de calcul classique pour optimiser les paramètres six faire tourner le circuit mesurer les chaînes de bits en sortie
en cherchant la solution la plus probable maintenant quelques points à noter ici
j'ai utilisé le niveau d'optimisation trois pour mon exemple à 5 qubit mais ce n'était peut-être pas nécessaire et la bonne réponse pourrait
encore être retournée la plupart du temps à un niveau d'optimisation inférieur parce que la profondeur du circuit était assez faible pour le cas à 5
qubit mais pour les 100 qubit et une grande profondeur de circuit tu auras presque certainement besoin du niveau le plus élevé
d'optimisation pour trouver la bonne réponse garde aussi en tête que l'une des parties les plus difficiles d'un workflow typique à l'échelle utilitaire
c'est l'étape de mapping et trouver un graphe qui correspond bien à la topologie heavy hex d'IBM si tu faisais
ce travail depuis zéro c'est indéniablement là que tu passerais une grande partie de ton temps pour l'instant cette partie a été
WEBVTT
faite pour toi parce que ce n'est pas le point principal de cet exercice mais garde en tête que c'est quelque chose qu'on devra
pratiquer et faire tourner un travail à grande échelle n'est pas toujours simple on va approfondir ça
davantage dans l'épisode 4 ton circuit final va évidemment sembler beaucoup plus désordonné que le circuit qui a tourné sur 5 qubit
mais d'un autre côté je trouve que regarder ce circuit et voir combien de gates il a et savoir que tu as
la capacité de le faire tourner réellement sur de vrais processeurs quantiques est plutôt
impressionnant et voici ma solution finale tu peux voir que l'algorithme est certainement capable de regrouper ces
nœuds en deux groupes identifiant prétendument la meilleure coupe Max qui les divise en passant des deux ensembles
à la ligne de coupe max elle-même est triviale partout où la couleur change le long des lignes qui connectent les nœuds désigne
l'endroit où la ligne de coupe max doit être dessinée quand je l'ai fait tourner la valeur de coupe max que j'ai pu atteindre est
84 alors essaie toi-même et dis-moi dans les commentaires si tu obtiens quelque chose de similaire essaie trois couches peut-être quatre essaie
de changer les poids entre les nœuds et vois comment ça change le résultat il y a beaucoup d'expériences intéressantes
qu'on peut faire avec qaoa rappelle-toi maintenant qu'il n'est pas garanti que j'ai juste trouvé la meilleure solution possible
on sait que c'est une bonne solution mais pour s'amuser je te lance le défi d'essayer de me battre vois si tu peux obtenir quelque chose
de mieux que 84 en conclusion qaoa est un algorithme très dynamique
et il y a beaucoup d'heuristiques et encore beaucoup à explorer il offre beaucoup de place pour apprendre de nouvelles
choses sur le domaine de l'optimisation en général il y a eu beaucoup de travaux récents dans le domaine de l'optimisation comme
en témoigne l'ensemble des articles d'archive qui ont récemment été publiés en ligne sur qaoa ou l'optimisation et ce qui est
vraiment cool c'est que finalement tous ces articles ne sont pas que des articles théoriques les théoriciens ont travaillé et étudié
qaoa pendant des années mais maintenant les expérimentateurs s'impliquent parce qu'on a enfin le matériel
comme les processeurs d'IBM qui sont capables de faire tourner beaucoup de ces expériences on passe de l'espace imaginatif
au monde réel et c'est très excitant oui il reste encore beaucoup de travail à faire et il y a encore
beaucoup d'erreurs sur lesquelles on doit comprendre comment les gérer mais on fait des progrès rapides et toi qui regardes cette
vidéo si tu es arrivé jusqu'ici tu es capable de faire tourner ces expériences toi-même vas-y essaie de faire tourner ta propre
expérience à 100 qubit et dis-nous comment ça s'est passé suis le tutoriel et tu seras en de bonnes mains et si tu as
des questions ou si tu bloques ne t'inquiète pas on a tous ressenti ça ou eu ces mêmes questions quand on a commencé à
apprendre ça fais de ton mieux dis-nous quelles questions tu rencontres et on se retrouve la prochaine fois
[Music]